[Applause]  cantor comes crashing in scoops it up  contact cantor fighting for it wrapped  up by derozan and now he's got a few  choice words for demar derozan players  trying to get separated  and it is starting to get chippy down in  san antonio cantor  now taking a liking to some of the  contacts he dealt with and derozan  obviously trying to fight for the rock  [Applause]  too  [Applause]  he's getting hit a lot even before the  whistle and then after the whistle  he got hit again so of course he's going  to be upset about that turns around  sees that it's derozan delivering the  contact and lets him know how he feels  about it  never saw